salut vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui on
va tourner la suite extrêmement demandés
de cette vidéo là sur des expériences
psychologiques ont été faites sur le
cerveau tout ça dans le but de mieux le
comprendre et vous allez voir que
parfois les conclusions sont
surprenantes
loïc jeunes entrepreneurs génériques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la deuxième vidéo de cette série
et il ya encore de la matière beaucoup
vu vos réactions et vos commentaires la
dernière fois on verra pour faire un
épisode 3 ça dépendra de vos réactions
là dans cette vidéo des legs des
commentaires et du nombre de vues en
tout cas abonnez-vous pour pas raté
ensuite l'épisode 3
nous avons commencé à parler des singes
de henry arlon des singes de arlon on
appelle cette expérience comme ça alors
attention
arlon a vécu de 1905 à 1981 donc
autre époque autre rapport à ce qui est
de antho logiquement bien ou mal son but
était de comprendre et d'étudier la
formation qu'il y ait un enfant un bébé
avec sa mère que ce soit du point de vue
de la dépendance affective ou la
dépendance à la nourriture que lui
fournit sa mère à cette époque les
psychanalystes penser qu'un enfant
s'attacher à sa mère via son besoin de
nourriture et comme elle elle compenser
ce besoin comme elle offrait la
nourriture et ben forcément ça crée
l'affection à ce moment là lui voulait
voir si c'était vraiment sale délire
donc il a pris des bébés singes des
résume t il les a séparés de leur mère
corps les élever dans des cages et c'est
là où je dis que c'est moralement hyper
contestable évidemment une fois le bébé
dans la cage ils avaient le choix entre
deux mers possible défaut ce maire qui
avait été placée dans la cage
une quête est faite entièrement en fil
de fer etc avaient un biberon avec du
lin l'intérieur qui était accroché à
elle et que le bébé pouvait prendre pour
se nourrir et une autre qui était en
tissu la première chose significatif
c'est que les bébés contrairement du
coup à ce qu'ont pensé par rapport au
fait qu'est une mère qu'est la
nourriture et l'autre pas ont passé la
majorité de leur temps près de la mer en
tissu donc à la recherche de confort et
d'affection il est allé plus loin dans
l'expérience en plaçant les bébés dans
une cage où il y avait qu'une seule des
deux mers et pour faire des comparatifs
donc un coup c'était un bébé avec la mer
en fer et le lait d'accrocher un coup
c'était un bébé avec la mer en tissu et
pas de nourriture accroche et bien ceux
qui étaient avec la fausse mère en tissu
avaient plus tendance à avoir confiance
en eux et comment on le sait c'est parce
que il explorait le territoire il allait
chercher
il revenait et c'est alors que les
autres restaient accrochés derrière où
près de la mer en faire mais ne surtout
pas aller plus loin à droite et à gauche
le deuxième comportement qui a été
observé c'est que lorsqu'il y avait
quelque chose qui faisait peur par
exemple il faisait un bruit très
effrayant il est tombé quelque chose et
c'est les bébés singes avec un maire en
tissu courait près d'elle et se
blottissent est contre elle les bébés
singes qui était avec la mer en faire et
qui avait le biberons remplis de lait
oeufs se recroqueviller ou tourner dans
la cage après 100 buts très effrayé il
n'avait pas de point de repère donc on
c'est à partir de ce moment là que les
bébés singes
on vraiment se blottir contre leur mère
pas pour un besoin de nourriture mais
par un vrai besoin d'affection besoin
d'affection mais aussi besoin de
contacts besoin de chaleur besoin de
serrer quelqu'un contre soi si c'est
vrai pour les bébés singes on sait que
c'est probablement vrai aussi pour les
bébés humains ce qu'il fout quand même
c'est carlo à l'époque c'était
complètement à contre-courant d'aller
contre les psychanalystes et les
behavioriste qui eux penser que cet
attachement qui avaient un bébé avec sa
mère était forcément lié au deal de la
nourriture
elle me nourrit donc je vais l'aimer on
ne pensait vraiment ça à l'époque
et donc lui s'en est pris clairement
plein les dents pour être montés au
créneau et avoir dit le contraire
nous allons parler de l'épuisement de
lego et du billet de contraintes de
baume hester en gros il s'était dit la
volonté
si ça se trouve c'est un petit peu comme
comme une bouteille d'eau qui
contiendraient de l'eau et los tres
cette volonté c'est à dire qu'il y en a
un stock assez déterminés pour une
journée et c'est pas à l'infini voici
les titres qu'il a mis en place il a mis
des participants des volontaires dans
une pièce où il y avait deux magnifiques
gâteaux fort appétissant il faut savoir
que les participants n'avaient pas
encore mangé et des radis juste dire à
10 ans ya pas de boy a pâti n ya rien
aux gays et l'a dit vous devez résister
vous devez pas manger des gâteaux vous
devez manger les radis c'est tout ce que
vous avez le droit vraiment vous n'avez
pas le droit de manger des gâteaux
il ya un autre groupe qu'a eu le droit
de faire ça également mais eux ils
avaient le droit de manger ce qu'ils
voulaient des gâteaux les radis ce
qu'ils voulaient ces deux groupes
individuellement on ensuite été mis dans
une autre pièce où ils devaient résoudre
un puzzle très compliqué ce qui a été
montré de manière significative c'est
que ceux qui avaient résisté aux gâteaux
ont abandonné le puzzle plutôt parce
qu'il était quasiment un fusible et donc
ils ont lâché beaucoup plus tôt que ce
qu'avait le droit de manger des gâteaux
plutôt que les radis parce que quoi
qu'il arrive et ce serait quand même
nourri à caral y avait une quantité
suffisante
donc ce n'était pas la notion fin
c'était foutu manger des gâteaux des
radis bouwmeester a rappelé à
l'épuisement de lego lauranne nord green
a appelé ça le biais de contraintes
en gros pour laure anne laure green on a
un état froid et un état show d'état
froissé admettons j'ai déjà mangé et je
me retrouve face à quelque chose de très
appétissant que j'ai pas le droit de
manger ça ne pose pas de problème mais
je vais sous-estimé l'attrait qu'il
aurait pu avoir envers moi si j'avais eu
faim donc je ne vais pas me protéger
pour la prochaine fois où je réfère à
cette situation
ce qui fait que si je suis dans un état
chaud c'est à dire là j'ai faim et la
chose sur laquelle je veux je dois avoir
de la volonté c'est quelque chose à
laquelle il est dur de résister vu mon
état
eh bien je vais céder parce que j'ai pas
assez appréhendé au préalable la
résistance qu'il fallait avoir par
rapport à ça parce que aujourd'hui c'est
ça quand même que bien on a des preuves
qu'on peut travailler notre volonté et
l'acquérir et un petit peu la muscler en
fait qu'elles soient de plus en plus
efficace en gros si vous résistez à
quelque chose aujourd'hui et demain
peut-être que ce sera de plus en plus
simple de résister à cette chose là
alors là c'est peut-être ma préférée de
la vidéo c'est une bombe atomique qui a
posé en 1970 david rosenhan dans le
milieu psychiatrique
à cette époque pour lui il se dit que
tout ce qui a trait aux maladies
mentales et à la psychiatrie est trop
liés à l'interprétation individuelle et
subjectif des médecins en gros on ne s'y
connaît pas assez il n'y a pas assez
d'éléments factuels qui permettent de
déterminer que telle personne est
atteinte de telles maladies mentales ou
pas il en est tellement persuadé qu'ils
lancent une étude dans son coin il
envoie huit personnes à lui aux urgences
et cette personne-là déclarent qu'elles
ont des hallucinations auditives
ok donc ça elles le disent elle explique
et du coup les huit se font interné dans
un hôpital psychiatrique sauf que partir
du moment où elles ont mis un pied dans
l'hôpital de psychiatric elles ont
toujours au fait normalement l on
parlait normalement elles ne seront plus
jamais dit qu'elle avait de nouveau des
hallucinations auditives ou des choses
comme ça bref elles ont repris leur
comportement de tous les jours
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dès que
ces huit personnes sont arrivés aux
urgences elles ont été diagnostiqués
comme étant schizophrène et c'est ça qui
les a conduits à l'internement
mais comme durant l'internement n'y
avait plus aucun signal de leur
schizophrénie
ils ont interprété l'absence de
symptômes comme faisant partie
intégrante de leur maladie maladie qui
je le rappelle n'existe pas du tout
c'était même pas simulé ça a été juste
une déclaration une seule fois aux
urgences
rosen and a révélé le pot-aux-roses que
tout ça c'était pour une étude qu'il
avait mis en place et ces mêmes
l'hôpital en question et d'autres
hôpitaux sont montré hyper sceptiques en
zone
mouais faut voir on n'est pas sûr que ce
soit vrai visage se trouvaient au fond
d'eux il était schizophrène et la laub
ces messages génie ce gars rosenhan
laisse courir la rumeur qui va lancer
d'autres tests de toute manière pour
confirmer tout son étude
donc il laisse se répandre cette
nouvelle là dans tous les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et dans tous les centres
d'internement
sauf qu'il n'envoie personne à part les
huit premiers il en voit plus personne à
compter de ce jour à partir du moment où
il a annoncé cette nouvelle que l'étude
allez continuer qu'il allait envoyer
d'autres personnes l'hôpital en question
dans laquelle il avait envoyé les huit
premiers ont déterminé qu'il ya
quarante-huit personnes qui faisait
semblant et 23 qui était suspect et qui
si ça se trouve faisait semblant à
alors que là pour le coup il avait
envoyé personne grâce à lui sa améliorer
la rigueur dont faisait preuve ensuite
les médecins pour faire les diagnostics
psychiatriques
sachant en même temps qu'ils avaient
cette question deux autos logique de est
ce que c'est bien de notre faute de
poser un mauvais diagnostic si on nous
fait un témoignage de mauvais symptôme
si on nous ment en clair est-ce que
c'était à eux de déterminer que les gens
étaient que les personnes étaient des
personnes qui mentait ou pas en tout cas
ça a complètement révolutionné troublé
et fait avancer en fait dans un sens le
milieu psychiatrique
l'utilité attendu où la théorie des
perspectives de kahneman et verse qui
l'utilité attendu c'est la manière la
plus logique la plus raisonner la plus
rationnelle de dévaluer un risque en
fait on va faire un exemple concret
c'est un exemple que vous allez perdre
de l'argent quoi qu'il arrive vous allez
perdre de l'argent
soit vous avez d'un côté un choix à
faire ou vous avez 100% de chances de
perdre 15 15 euros soit de l'autre côté
vous avez un autre choix où vous avez
que 5 % de chances de perdre 400 euros
donc vous êtes obligés de fermer ces
deux choix assez on va dire
intuitivement et émotionnellement on
ferait le choix de dire ben je prends le
5 % de chances de perdre 400 euros
plutôt que d'être sûr de perdre de
l'argent
c'est ce qui paraît on a envie de le
tenter dans la réalité dans le rationnel
si on fait le calcul de liquidités
attendues
on va faire un soit 15 1% pour cent soit
15 donc ça nous fait 15
on va le comparer avec l'autre chiffre
donc c'était 5 % de 400 euros donc 5% sa
fille 0,05 donc on va faire 0 0 5 x 400
et le bon choix à faire c'est le
résultat le plus bas
donc on a tout intérêt à être certain de
perdre 15 euros plutôt que de tenter
notre chance en perdre 400 la théorie
des perspectives de calm and adverse qui
elle ne démontre que on évalue
différemment nos chances de gagner
quelque chose versus nos chances de
perdre quelque chose c'est pas les mêmes
biais c'est pas la même émotion et du
coup ça fait pas la même intuition et on
n'a pas la même rationalité des deux
côtés suivant qu'on évalue une chance de
gain potentiel ou une
une chance de pertes potentielles ils
ont démontré qu'on a ce réflexe la
d'être prêt à miser sur une grosse perte
potentielle plutôt que sur une petite
perte sûr à 100%
imaginez vous êtes en train de marcher
dans la rue et puis là il ya quelque
chose qui qui qui brille dans votre oeil
et c'est un peu gênant et vous regardez
il ya quelque chose de caché sous une
feuille par terre vous avez soulevé la
feuille et là vous trouvez un diamant
havre est un vrai beau gros diamant avec
en plus comme par hasard à côté un
certificat d'authenticité est là et bien
vous avez une joie immense qui rentrent
en vous et vous mettez à sourire et bien
apparemment ça ne se passe pas comme ça
c'est même plutôt l'inversé
et ça c'est la théorie de james times
pour james hellen 'je sais un stimulus
qui va provoquer une réaction
physiologique en l'occurrence le fait de
sourire et c'est le fait de sourire qui
va provoquer ensuite la joie et c'est
non pas la joie qui provoque le sourire
pour étayer son propos james avait un
contre exemple il disait que si vous
rencontrez un ours féroce un moment
donné et que vous partez en courant en
fait c'est parce que vos jambes
tremblent que vous avez de l'adrénaline
dans le sang et que vous êtes en train
de fuir que vous ressentez l'émotion de
la peur c'est ça la théorie de l'émotion
en fait c'est tous ces facteurs
physiologiques qui font que vous
ressentez de la peur à l'issue de ces
facteurs physiologiques début du 20e
siècle le physiologiste walter kahn a
voulu démontrer que cette théorie de
l'émotion était complètement fausse et
donc il a fait bon un truc horrible il a
empêché via la moelle épinière de
certains chiens d'avoir un feedback
physiologique pour voir si ces chiens-là
ressentait encore des émotions il
ressentait encore des émotions et il ya
quelques années il ya eu de nouvelles
études qui ont prouvé en réalité que la
théorie des émotions notre jeunesse
l'âge était vrai ça veut dire que quand
on se force à sourire on va changer un
peu notre état d'esprit notre mindset
pour quelque chose de plus positif
puisqu'il est habitué à ça et c'est vrai
d'ailleurs on avait fait une vidéo à
l'époque avec ses villages sur ma chaîne
où elle m'apprenait à faire des émotions
etc et elle dans son jeu de comédienne
quand elle déclenche tous les tous les
signaux de la tristesse et tout
l'expression de la tristesse alors à
l'arrivée plus facilement à pleurer et
les études récentes ont montré aussi
également que les personnes qui avaient
trop de botox ou du botox depuis trop
longtemps ou qui s'en arrange été trop
souvent du moins parce que ça reste pas
éternellement
elle avait moins de feedback et du coup
elle avait des émotions qui était un peu
étouffé un peu moindre
on va terminer avec les stades moreau de
colbert qui est quelque chose qui nous
concerne tous depuis notre enfance et
qui nous concerne encore aujourd'hui
pour vous mettre juste aussi dans le
contexte que ce que parfois c'est quand
même intéressant il faut savoir que
laurence kohlberg a vécu de 1927 à 1987
il a étudié le comportement des enfants
et plus précisément le comportement
moral pour essayer de voir s'il y avait
un stéréotype est de faire une sorte de
classement de stade dans les
comportements moraux
en gros ils représentaient des dilemmes
moraux et il l'étudié il étayé leur
réponse pour kohlberg ya trois niveaux
de développement moral et ses trois
niveaux sont eux mêmes subdivisés en
deux ce niveau le stade
1 qu'est le premier stade convient
durant notre enfance selon lui c'est le
stade moral on détermine ce qui est bien
et ce qui est mal en fonction de ce qui
est puni ou pas tout simplement on a pas
de jugement là dessus
le stade 2 c'est celui on détermine ce
qui est bien et mal en fonction de ce
que les autres veulent et de ce qu'ils
nous rapportent une récompense le stade
3 et en fonction de ce qui plaît aux
autres sens du bien et du mal à l'omc
comportement et en fonction de ce qui
les aide
le stade iv c'est le respect de
l'autorité le stade 5 donc là on passe
au troisième niveau et ça veut pas dire
que tout le monde atteindra ce stade
d'ailleurs dans sa vie c'est pas c'est
pas obligé
c'est le moment où les enfants
comprennent que le droit individuel de
la personne peut passer au dessus du
droit de l'autorité donc en gros qu'il
ya un droit moral individuelles qui peut
passer au dessus des règles
un exemple très dur et très concret mais
malgré l'autorité parentale
si un parent et violent avec son enfant
et bien l'enfant va comprendre en fait
que c'est pas normal et qui peut par
exemple aller de dénoncer ou aller
chercher de l'aide ailleurs parce que
parce que cette règle est injuste en
fait je caricature de ouf 1 et le stade
si c'est le plus élevé c'est notre
comportement vis-à-vis du bien et du mal
sont déterminés après par notre propre
éthique et nos propres valeurs d'égalité
dans très de fraternité de cesser notre
justice personnelle que l'on a
construite après au fil des années au
fil de nos expériences et au fil de nos
jugements colbert penser que seulement
10 % des adultes atteignent ce stade
morale c'est pas quelque chose de
généraliser pour le et après plus tard
il aura même jusqu'à et et dire que si
elle se trouve le stade si c'est pas
forcément un style distinct que c'est un
peu autre chose
alors comme tout
les études et les théories celle-ci
controversé même celle d'avant il ya
toujours des contradicteurs et après il
ya plus ou moins de preuves comme quoi
c'est controversé et si elles sont où il
y en aura un peu plus tard s'est jamais
vraiment figé dans le temps ce genre de
choses
alors qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de
tout ça parce qu'encore une fois
certaines études sont controversés
aujourd'hui mais c'est quand même
intéressant de les connaître parce que
ça nous montre aussi à l'époque comme on
apprenait le cerveau est encore une fois
dans 20 ans ou dans trente ans on dira
ah mais c'est marrant il pensait ça en
2020 alors que vraiment c'est
complètement obsolète aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs je vous raconterai quelques
fun fact sur ce sujet là aujourd'hui
/ - instagram qui doit s'afficher ici
quelque part autour de moi tous les
jours je fais des fun fact sur des
sujets assez intéressant comme ça et
vous pouvez aussi me voir dire des trucs
intéressants tout en étant drôle tout en
vous bluffant et tout en vous abonnant
vous bluffez vous même dans mon
spectacle sur scène qui s'appelle
singularité en gros c'est un spectacle
de mentalisme ou quand vous sortez de la
salle vous vous dites mais je savais pas
qu'il était drôle ce mec est que moi
aussi je pouvais être moi-même mentalist
et que je savais faire ce que je veux
faire
bref la tournée de ce spectacle est dans
la description c'est la dernière tournée
pour ce spectacle qu'on a décalé avec
tout ce qui se passait durant le
confinement c'est à dire que après le
mois de mai 2021 je ne jouerai plus
jamais ce spectacle
venez vous prenez votre place au zénith
de paris la date helvète ouf le 20
novembre 2020
il ya des surprises ya des invités juste
incroyable la l'image que vous voyez
apparaître ces les places qui restent en
gros tout ce qui est noir et déjà pris
donc vous pouvez prendre votre place je
crois que c'est à partir de 29 euros
le lien est dans la bio si vous ne
connaissiez pas je m'appelle fabien
olicard vous pouvez vous abonner à cette
chaîne youtube
allez-y c'est gratuit pour ne pas rater
la prochaine vidéo je vous conseille
chaudement d'activer la cloche là qu'est
la vidéo si elle vous a plu vous avez vu
deux vidéos apparaître ça c'est la
première vidéo de cette série convient
de tourner donc sur les expériences sur
le cerveau en psychologie et ça c'est
une vidéo sur si les extraterrestres
existent
comment ça se fait qu'ils sont pas
aujourd'hui parmi nous vous avez les
répondre à cette vidéo à très bientôt
ciao